[Applause]
every year is a countenance of
challenges great challenges
[Music]
we're talking about a continent that has
begun a process of modernization but
there's still a lot to do develop the
true Health Network boost industry
mechanized agriculture and of course
responds to the enormous challenge of
improving education if we look at
results from recent decades and identify
the countries that have taken the
greatest economic leaps we can see that
the common denominator has been an
effort to implement high-quality
educational systems in countries such as
Japan South Korea or Singapore the
commitment to have first-rate education
systems really facilitated their
economic transition within a few years
all of these countries went from poor
rudimentary economies to becoming high
value-added economic powers that is
exactly what is now happening in China
of course China's success is due to many
factors but throughout this entire
process of economic takeoff education
played an important role and not only
for economic reasons but also social
cultural and political ones
and now it's Africa's turn
[Music]
schools that aren't schools obviously
getting sub-saharan Africa to the
education level of developed countries
will be a mammoth task and it will take
decades and just as a house is
constructed from the foundations up all
kinds of public and private
organizations of invested millions of
dollars in reducing illiteracy and
improving schooling throughout
sub-saharan Africa for more than three
decades however the challenge is so
enormous that there's still a lot to do
[Music]
for example a lack of access to
education in Africa is one of its
biggest problems despite all the efforts
made more than 20% of children aged
between 6 and 11 still don't go to
school
and if we talk about children aged
between 12 and 14 a figure rises above
30 percent the usual reason given for
this situation is the need in the
poorest regions for children to work in
the fields from a young age and the
difficulty in meeting the cost of
education because you see even though
the free public education model has been
adopted widely throughout the African
continent parents still have to pay
expenses such as uniforms shoes books or
transportation and of course in such a
poor region this is often rather
complicated but if you think that the
lack of access or not being able to pay
for expenses are the only problems
hindering education in Africa you're
very very wrong the other great and
perhaps most significant challenge
facing educational systems in Africa has
to do with the very poor teaching
quality and with the wasteful and
uncontrolled use of public funds how
many of you might not be thinking well
Simon I mean surely you didn't expect
Africa to have Ivy League class colleges
after just a few years but well wait
because when we talk about poor quality
teachers we mean the standard is really
really low
[Music]
in many African countries such as Sierra
Leone it's common to find fake teachers
these are teachers who receive a salary
from the government but who neither
teach nor work since 2009 in Sierra
Leone alone more than 6,000 fake
teachers have been detected and
eliminated from the state payroll
although to be fair this doesn't only
happen in Africa it's a frequent problem
in other poor countries as well in
Pakistan for example there were more
than 8,000 schools that received funds
from the stage but didn't really exist
these were simply ghost schools where
did that money go let's just says better
not to ask but that's not all even when
teachers do show up well let's just say
that in Africa skipping classes often
has more to do with the teachers than
the students check this out
[Music]
yep in sub-saharan Africa it is common
for teachers just not to show up at
school some studies show that in
countries such as Kenya on Nigeria this
absenteeism affects 15% of the entire
workforce but if this already sounds
crazy well listen up in Kenya this
percentage rises to almost 50% if we
include teachers who go to school but
don't actually go into the classroom to
teach
and then there's the fact that it isn't
uncommon that many teachers who do teach
to have well difficulties reading or not
really have a mastery of even basic
mathematics even if their mathematics
teachers basically it's a full-fledged
disaster and no opening more schools
isn't enough this isn't going to solve
the problem more things are needed but
hold on a second because not all of the
news is bad here in addition to public
schools and the schools that NGOs opens
with cooperation aid there is another
alternative that has recently gained a
strong following in the region and
that's private low cost education
private and low cost education appearing
in the same sentence
even though in many parts of the world
private education is reserved for people
with high incomes in Africa this barrier
is eroding could private education help
overcome the problems of the continents
educational systems well I'm pretty sure
that's a question that you've never
asked yourself to delve deeper into this
phenomenon and to figure out what's
going on here in this video we're going
to focus on the examples of two very
different countries Kenya and Liberia
Kenya is one of the stars of Africa's
takeoff
since 2013 its economy has been growing
at an average of more than 5 percent per
year
Liberia on the other hand is still one
of the 10 poorest countries in the world
and is bogged down with a lot of social
problems and a lot of economic problems
so what's the country is poor as Liberia
doing with private education how and why
would a struggling country promote a
private education model
Liberia aware of the disaster the
Liberian government has noticed that it
has a huge problem so huge that it's
practically impossible for them to
manage it themselves after 14 years of
civil war and constant epidemics
education has remained a 2nd 3rd or 4th
level priority add to this uncontrolled
corruption and the failure of public
services is evidence of course
disastrous management goes hand in hand
with disastrous results
however the Liberian government has
decided to break the malls and bet on a
fairly novel way to ensure that the
poorest have better access to education
[Music]
the people responsible for this strategy
change are the largest company dedicated
to low-cost private education in Africa
that's the bridge international
academies a company founded in 2008 in
Kenya by 2 American friends it currently
has more than 600 schools that offer
education to a hundred and twenty
thousand students but of course it isn't
the only company dedicated to this
activity not at all in fact there's also
the rising academies another of the two
main low-cost private school companies
in Africa which was founded by British
and Canadian entrepreneurs but as we've
don't have time to talk about all the
emerging companies we're going to today
focus on bridge which is the largest of
them all and the first question we need
to ask ourselves is where has it funded
well nowadays it can continue operating
mostly thanks to the support of
institutions such as the World Bank and
with donations from business
heavyweights like Mark Zuckerberg or
Bill Gates
because in most cases these kinds of
educational companies they aren't
profitable they only appear to be viable
because of the donations that they
receive for example let's take the case
of bridge international in 2016 they
declared an income of 16 million dollars
but had operating losses of 12 million
that means that total costs were a
whopping 28 million dollars meaning
their costs were 75% greater than their
income but just a second don't think
we're talking about something like an
NGO here not at all these companies are
for-profit what happens is that they
conceive a long-term business model they
hope that the economic development that
has begun in many African regions will
soon allow to reap the benefits and of
course in the meantime they received
support in the forms of multiple
donations such as those of Bill Gates
that more than compensate them for their
business losses but they often receive
these donations precisely because they
have a feasibility plan that is because
they expect it to be profitable and
therefore an autonomous and sustainable
project in the medium term of course
spending is easy but managing to create
a self-sustaining project as something
else and it is precisely for this reason
and despite all these losses that the
company continues with its expansion
plan it's all thanks to the more than a
hundred and fourteen million dollars it
has earned in investments and donations
surprised while the fact is that in 2016
the government of Liberia the country
where less than 40 percent of children
receive primary education decided to
work with bridge international why well
because it's obvious that public
education wasn't working in the country
[Music]
teachers don't show up even though
they're paid by the government there are
no books training is very weak school
infrastructure is not safe we have to do
something radical
George Warner X Minister of Education in
Liberia
[Music]
the point is that the Liberian
government signed an agreement for
bridge international to operate 93
public schools with more than 27,000
students access to these schools is
still free the government pays for the
students today's this is the largest
agreement signed between an African
government and a private education
company and this experiment seems to be
quite a success in level tests students
from schools managed by bridge
international achieve much better
results than students from schools
operated by the state to give you an
idea of the divide the bridge students
results can be a hundred percent higher
that is the bridge students do twice as
well as students from government
controlled schools but just a second
because in spite of these positive
results not every country is making
things easy for this type of Education
business take for example Kenya the very
country where bridge International was
born
[Music]
Kenya's Miss trust let's not fool
ourselves private schools can pose a
threat to state controlled education and
many governments don't like that neither
the public school teachers that's
exactly what's happening in Kenya where
the National Teachers Union has been
conducting a very tough campaign against
the low-cost private schools model for
many years supposedly they are against
the teachers in these types of centers
who don't have a government license this
is even though the student's academic
results are much better bridge is
unauthorized and illegal Wilson's ocean
secretary general of the Kenyan and
National Union of teachers there is some
truth however to their arguments the
company itself recognizes it technically
were breaking the law but so are
thousands of other schools who are
operating like this
Shannon Mae co-founder of bridge
international academies among other
things the educational programs aren't
written in the country they're destined
for nor do they meet the local
government's requirements they're
usually written abroad in bridges case
educational performance is even
evaluated by Harvard professors which to
tell the truth and without meaning to
offend everyone is probably not such a
bad thing when you consider Kenya's
politicians
[Music]
of course not everything is rosy with
the private model then sometimes
unpleasant situations occur companies
like bridge international are still
for-profit companies which require
parents to keep up payments and that can
be a struggle in a place like Africa
however what's the alternative public
schools where teachers go to class when
they feel like it or where maths classes
are taught by people who hardly know how
to multiply in sub-saharan Africa
governments have proven very ineffective
in providing public services that's why
many alternatives are emerging in some
cases they are companies and in others
they are nonprofit organizations the
important thing is that these
initiatives saw revolutionising
education in Africa
could it be that investing in private
low-cost schools that aim to be
profitable is one of the best ways to
help develop quality education in Africa
could it be the investments are better
than mere handouts I'll leave your
answer in the comments below and I
really do hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos also please do check out our
friends at reconsider media they
provided the vocals in this episode but
we're not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting us
in our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you next time
[Music]